Have you ever had one of those pinch me moments
where you can't believe that this is your life?
Today was one of those days for me
since I got invited to my first Bottega show.
The ones that have stuck around for a while
know how much I love the brand,
so it's truly an honor that I got invited today.
Even though I had two hours to get ready,
I was still running late,
so I hopped in the car and headed over to the venue.
Once I got there,
we took all the pictures and did the press moments before
I headed inside and saw all these comfy seats for the first time.
Once everyone was seated, the show started.
It was so classic but playful.
I loved all the different layers and the oversized coats,
the silhouettes.
But what I still think about is this white dress that was so stunning.
I caught up with some familiar faces after,
did some more press I couldn't do before the show,
and then we headed to the after party that was right next door.
Was lovely
chatting to Matthew about his collection and thought process
and all the work that went into his beautiful designs.